What is that distinction?
every sunnah is a hadith But
not every hadith is a sunnah.
Right? So when we look at
Hadith We see that the prophet
many things have been narrated
to us. I mean, the companions
meticulously documented and
noticed every little thing
about the prophet
religious things, things that
have to do with revelation and
things that don't necessarily
have to do with revelation.
Such as what he liked to eat,
certain dishes that he likes
specifically. the companions
narrated that the prophet
favorite cut from a sheep is
the shoulder. This is the
shoulder. Is that a religious
sunnah? Not necessarily. That's
something that's of preference.
If a person came along and
said, well, I prefer the tongue
or I prefer some other part
with this person be
disregarding the sunnah if that
was not his favorite part. The
answer is no. This is a natural
thing. This is what the
scholars referred to as Umur
Jubilee. and these things have
their own ruling However, the
prophet was also narrated to
have commanded that an animal
be slaughtered in such a way
and that said and so forth.
That's a religious aspect. and
so The companions they narrated
everything that they saw from
the prophet said, everything.
Narrates the amount of white
hairs that were in his beard
and head. Before his death.
Now, this isn't necessarily a
sunnah. This is a hadith,
right? It's a hadith. It's a
narration. the is what the
prophet said or did or
acknowledged with the intention
that Allah be worshiped through
this these means in this way.
This is the way that he
worshiped Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. This is the sunnah. And
so in that, there are many
things. There are some things
that are abrogated. There are
some things which he did before
and didn't do later. There are
things that he did later that
were not intentional as to be
followed. There were things
that he did in private, that
were personal things. There
were things that he did in
public, etcetera. And so,
distinguishing between a hadith
and a sunnah can be somewhat of
a cumbersome task at times.
this book is essentially taking
all of the hadith and the
narrations and documenting the
of the prophet
for the most part. We are in
the chapter regarding things
that the prophet
prohibited
or disliked or
discouraged be said. Or things
that someone may do in ways of
speech. Whether that be things
that people say or things the
way people say things etcetera.
Allah he says
Muslim. Muslim
[Silence]
times people confuse, insulting
with vulgarity. It doesn't have
to be vulgar. It doesn't, you
don't have to use bad words for
it to be considered insulting
Insulting is saying or implying
anything that articulates
disrespect that are that you
mean to demean the person that
you are insulting. This could
be in any speaking about
someone's parent or father or
tribe. It could be speaking
about someone's country
speaking about someone's
origins, speaking about
someone's children, right? not
in the sense of admonishment
and that has its that has its
it's care that needs to be
taken but in the sense of
meaning to dispute that person.
Meaning to insult them. Meaning
to demean that person. This
could be anything that is in
their hand or outside of their
hand. insulting their race,
insulting their complexion,
insult their features. Saying
someone is an ugly person or
something of that sort. It
could also be in the sense of
this person has no man. You
have no manners. You are this,
that, any, anything that a
person says or implies to
another person that is
demeaning. And you mean to
demean that person. This is
insulting. Even if you don't
use bad words. If you use bad
words, it becomes worse
obviously. If you do this to
someone who is absent. This is
backbiting. If you do it to
someone who is present, then
this is, this is insulting.
Oftentimes, when someone
backbites another person,
speaks about them in their
absence. if you admonish them
and say, you know, don't speak
about the brother. He's not
even here to defend himself.
Something that What will
the person usually respond
immediately? So, imagine this
with me. Let's say, you're
speaking of, you know,
someone's speaking about
another person. And we say to
him, hey man, don't say that
about him. What do they usually
respond with?
I'll say it in his face.
there's another one too that
I'm looking for I said man,
don't say that about him. he'll
say
well it's true, right? So those
are the two things usually
people say. Either they'll say,
it's true or I'll say it to him
in his face, right? Well,
that's even worse, right? the
fact that you're willing to
insult someone to their face is
not a merit and is not
something that justifies Rebel.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
Has been explained by some of
the as one who insults people
in their absence and in their
presence. That's home as a
right? And it's also said that
Al Humaza is one who insults a
who who speaks ill about
another or insults a person.
Verbally with a gesture, right?
Whethe
r that be with by gesture
or by way, you know, winking or
something with their hands or
using their words. So, this
statement of, I'll say it to
his face. I've said it to him
before. You know, things like
that that people usually say to
defend their actions. This is
not justified and just
justification. This is
something which is which is
haram. And in a person's
absence, it's bad. But in a
person's presence, it's worse,
arguably. Why? because now you
are causing direct enmity
between yourself and this
individual. Interestingly
enough,
psychologically speaking most
people when they speak about
another person the listener
usually attributes those traits
to the person speaking.
Subconsciously. So,
psychologists have kind of done
some research and this is this
is obviously not why we obey
the prophet. We don't obey him
because Scientists say that
it's correct. We don't wait for
their
you know, their approval rather
it's the other way around but
it's just something that is to
be mentioned and that is that
they found that when a person
speaks about another person, so
let's say, a person comes to
you and says, you know, this
other person, he's this, he's
that, right? He's he's a liar
or he's ugly, right? What they
noticed is that most times the
listener on the subconscious
level usually comes to affirm
what this person said about the
other, affirm it for that
person who's speaking. So, if
you go and tell if if a person
goes and tells, you know, he's
a very ugly person. The
listener usually will describe
ugliness to the person
speaking. It's not a conscious
thing. It's just something that
usually happens. The point is,
is that you know, people who
backbite, people who are
insulting, it's not permissible
to listen to that but just keep
in mind that people that have
two faces were three or four
you're not special. They're not
telling you this because the
other person is is is bad and
you're good. They're telling
you this because you're willing
to listen. And in your absence
they're probably saying all
kinds of things about you as
well. That's usually how it
goes with people of that
fabric. So the point is is that
insulting a Muslim is a major
sin. And it is something which
is impermissible in Islam. The
more that person is reputable,
the more influential that
person is on the religion of
Allah or the Muslims, the more
serious that offense becomes.
So, in insulting or backbiting,
a Muslim is a major sin
backbiting a a scholar. Or
someone who is influential to
the Muslims, someone who's
influential to Islam. It
becomes worse because now,
you're not just bringing that
persons down but you're
bringing whatever that person
represents down as well and you
are causing misgivings. About
that person and what they
represent in the heart of the
listener. He says, why not?
Another thing which is
impermissible. Is that two
people if there's a group of
three that two of them pass
secrets between one another in
the presence of the third.
Meaning that they whisper to
each other something that they
don't want the other person to
hear. This is something which
is haram. It's mentioned in the
Quran. And the reason for this
is that it causes the other
person to have suspicions about
what you're speaking about. And
it causes them at least to feel
left out. Right? and this is
something which is
impermissible. Anything that
will make a Muslim sad, if it
is not absolutely necessary, is
not permissible. That is just a
general, a general rule. He
says,
and we covered a lot of these
last week. Another thing which
is impermissible is that a
woman described to her husband
another woman's features.
Another woman's features. This
is something which is
impermissible.
and that is that a woman's
features whatever she conceals
under her hijab is considered
to be a it's considered to be
something which is essentially
her secret and when you
describe what you've seen of
that person to another, this
becomes haram and obviously,
this is even worse. You know,
not just a woman describing
another woman to her husband
but that's what the narration
exactly says. What we can
derive from this any kind of
description that removes or
penetrates the veil of another
woman, right? or another man. A
woman may describe to her
friends
private aspects of her husband
or of a man that she was with
before or a man may which is
Of course, abhorred a woman may
describe to another
something private about her
husband or her previous husband
or a man may describe his
sister or someone of his family
to another man. Any kind of
description in this way is
haram. He mentioned that a
woman described the features of
another woman to her husband.
Why did he say it that way?
Because that's exactly what the
narration said. That's most
common, most commonly, a woman
will go, she'll be at a
gathering with other women,
she'll see them without hijab,
and in her banter with her
husband, she'll describe the
features of that woman to her
husband. This is something
which is haram, but anything in
that vein is impermissible.
Another is and **** Is that a
person in his dua say, oh
Allah, forgive me if you choose
to or if you will. This is
something that we discussed in
detail last week.
Another is that a person swear
by Allah too much constantly. I
swear by Allah, I swear by
Allah, Allah, he will Allah he
this is something that you know
it it's kind of demeans Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala's the
gravity of Allah's name in the
heart of the listener and the
person who is swearing.
The
Another thing which is
discouraged. Something that is.
impermissible is to describe
things in detail that should
only be referred to in passing,
right? And this happens a lot
Especially in our language, in
English, and the way that our
idioms are set up and the way
that our Words are are and the
way that the culture is because
the culture of the people is
what forms the language. and so
there are things that people
will say that are unnecessary.
for instance, a person and
you know, it's it's especially
bad when it's when it's a
female speaking to a male or
other females. But it's it's
not it's equally as it's it's
not appropriate for both
genders. But a woman has an
elegance about her. She has a
kind of mystique of beauty
about her. And if she does or
says things that removes that
veil it becomes even she's
making herself kind of in the
listener's mind and that
becomes somehow worse than
someone whom that is not his
hallmark. So, for instance, a
person instead of saying, I'd
to use the restroom. They
say, you know, I have to go
do this or do that in the
restroom and describe the kind
of bowel movement or the kind
of urination that they're going
to have. This is unnecessary.
This is not something that
should be said. Person just I
really have to go to the
bathroom. That's enough. Right?
To say I need to go do this in
the bathroom. That's
inappropriate. Right? Or for
instance if a woman is on her
cycle. You know she says.
you know, I'm on I'm on my
cycle or something of that
nature. That's fine. But to say
other things that are more
detailed. That's inappropriate.
And this this culture here that
we're in right now. This is
exactly the kind of stuff that
they're trying to get rid of.
You know. We have commercials.
Right? About things that are
very a good example of this is
how often do you see pictures
or commercials of a man or even
worse a woman sitting on the
toilet, right? So, all the
time. It's unnecessary. We
don't need to see that. its
demeaning and it's disgusting.
It's something that happens in
private. The prophet when he
would use the restroom, when he
would relieve himself, he would
go so far out that you couldn't
even see his whole body while
he was using the restroom and
we discussed this in previous
chapters. That a person must
conceal his private parts when
he uses the restroom and is
encouraged to conceal his whole
body when he's using the rest
right? And is encouraged. He
conceal his whole body while
he's using the restroom.
Because you don't want people
to see you in that light. Yes,
it's something that we all do.
Yes, it's something that is
common and we all use the
restroom. But it doesn't mean
we need to speak about it. It
doesn't need mean we need to
talk about it or demonstrate it
to one another. Right?
so now we have commercials with
you know commercials or movies
or what have you. People, you
know, sitting on the toilet to
use in the bathroom or you
know, a part in a movie will
come up where the person is
using the bathroom and show us
and give us sound and give us,
this is just unnecessary
vulgarity, right? we have
commercials about
We have commercials about
menstruation. You know, whether
it be pads or something
that for menstruation and
then we have women standing
there describing to us in
detail how this menstruation
takes place and what it's like
and how it should be and then
we say, oh this is liberating.
You know, it's liberating women
when they speak about these
things. This is just disgusting
vulgarity. It doesn't need to
be spoken about, right? these
are things that the human body
does that you keep to yourself,
right? you know, and the
examples of this are many.
you know, men describing
certain things about themselves
or describing certain things
about their acts or the extreme
intense hyper sexualized
vulgarity that goes on where
people describe their intimate
details of how they do what
with who. These are all things
which are impermissible and a
person should never speak about
in public.
[Silence]
Another thing which is
impermissible is to refer to
impermissible taxation as
rights. What is he talking
about? So is when and sometimes
people misunderstand taxation.
There are couple types of
taxation. There is taxation
that is absolutely haram. And
this is what is referred to as
El Mukuz. Taxation which is
absolutely haram is a king
or
how it used to be which is kind
of one of the ways that or how
we're taught that America was
initially established and that
is that they were fleeing from
the taxation of the British,
right? So, they came over here
and the king would send every
year for taxes to be taken from
the citizen reliving here but
they don't receive anything in
in return for this taxation.
It's just the king's right on
his people is that he taxed
them, right? They don't receive
anything in return. This is
what is referred to as El Mukus
in the
legisl
ation of Islam. This is
haram. And noone has the right
to collect. And noone has the
right to take these. Right?
Then we have other types of
taxation. I can't say all the
taxation that happens in
America is this but much
of it is taxes that we pay that
usually come back to us in some
way. Whether it be pave the
roads or hospitals or police,
access to police, or access to
fire, access to search and
rescue, things that,
right? This is a type of
taxation but it's not
considered mukus. And the
legislation of Islam. Because
it's not just something which
is taken with no return. It's
taken for a common good of the
rest of everyone in the in the
state, in the country, in the
community, and there has to be
a level of socialism for a
community to thrive properly
and notice I didn't say
socialism. I said a level of
socialism. There has to be a
level of us all getting
together and pulling our
resources together for everyone
to have a fair at essentials.
That that is fine. absolute
socialism communism and
stuff that. That's
obviously has nothing to do
with Islamic values. but one of
the things is that these kinds
of tax, this kind of taxation
which is haram taxation that we
mentioned the first type. For
this to be referred to as the
rights of the king or the
responsibility of the citizens.
That is as haram to refer to
something that in that
way. Cuz it's it's manipulating
the truth. This isn't the right
of the king. It's not the
responsibility of the citizens.
Right?
Another example of that is
Ribba. To refer to Riba as
right? Or interest. It's usury.
It's not interest. Interest is
giving something that is very
terrible of a nice name. It's
not interest. It's usury. And
it's called usury in the
English language for a reason
because you are using another
person. You're using his
his bad set of circumstances,
your your you are capitalizing
on another person's misfortune
to better align your pockets.
It's called usury and that's a
bad name. And that's good. Cuz
that's what it needs to be
called. When we call it things
interest, it becomes
business strategy, right?
the same thing happens in
Arabic. people refer to it
as and this is direct
translation of the word
interest. Scholars have
prohibited using this this
language to describe it. It
should be referred to as Ribba.
because it is haram and that's
what is referred to in the
Quran and when you change the
name of something, you change
its ruling. When you change its
name, you change. You change
its ruling, right? Another
example of that is referring to
as fees. You know, we can flip
it around and say, well, you
know, it's just a fee. Whatever
kind of feed that is. That's
another way that a Shaitan uses
to manipulate the truth, to
change its ruling. A Shaitan
was the first to do this and
recorded history in the Quran.
When he referred to the tree,
that Adam was urged to eat from
and prohibited by Allah, he
referred to it as Shaja
The everlasting, the tree of of
eternity, the eternal tree, or
a dominion that will never
diminish, right? That's giving
a very nice sounding name to
something that's very terrible.
the narrates to us and others
that the prophet said and
elsewhere
That a group of
consider intoxicants
permissible and they will do so
by changing the name instead of
calling it an intoxicant,
instead of calling it poison,
they'll refer to it with fancy
names that spark an air of
delight in the listener's mind.
This is something which is
haram and it's a type of lying.
It's a type of dishonesty. A
person when he speaks, he needs
to name good things with good
names and bad things with bad
names. Not vulgar names but
names that articulate the truth
about this thing.
I will
Another thing which is
impermissible is to refer. Now,
we spoke about money that is
haram referring to it or that
is spent in haram referring to
it with a good name. I get
calling usury interest or
calling illegal taxation, you
know, rights or or
responsibilities. On the other
side, it's how long to refer to
money that is spent on good
things with bad names. So, to
say for instance, that you gave
in charity this much where you
spent this on someone. You say,
you know, I lost that money
this year, right? I lost this
and this money. That money was
not lost. It's not considered a
loss. Only those who disbelieve
in Allah in the last day,
consider charity to be a loss.
Only those who believe, who who
disbelieve in Allah in the last
day, consider charity to be a
loss. Charity is a gain. It's
the only real gain actually.
Right? Because all of your
wealth is going to stay here on
Earth and you're going to
depart from it except for that
wealth that you spend for the
sake of Allah and then find
with Allah after your death.
That's the only real wealth
that you get to keep. Every
other wealth is going to stay
here on earth. Either be
someone else's or you're going
to
you know, consume that wealth
here on this earth.
Another thing which is
impermissible and you know,
each of these statements, each
of these sentences, honestly,
you could write an essay on.
These are actually very deep
subjects and they deserve more
time but in the in the interest
of time and in the interest of
continuity, we'd to keep a
particular flow going.
Otherwise, every one of these
statements that he's making,
there are narrations and entire
essays have been written
written on each of these
issues.
Another thing is to say
to say in this, you know, I've
spent so much money in this
world. kind of boasting
about the amount of money that
you've spent on your home or
this or that. Whatever it is.
this is something which is
as well impermissible.
Fema
the